c'est l'union
[Musique]
ne me
la voix de la soprano algérienne amel
brahim djelloul résonnera le 4 juillet
prochain sur le site du musée national
de port royal des champs à magny les
hameaux
après la période d'arrêt culturel due à
la crise sanitaire le musée le théâtre
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines souhaité
remettre les artistes sur le devant de
la scène
on s'était dit que c'était l'occasion
d'aller sur des labels ras des musiques
croisés ou des musiques plurielles comme
on veut et de voyager entre les les
rites méditerranée jusqu'à l'angleterre
et puis revenir en espagne essayé de
traverser à la fois les styles et les
époques
après les mélodies orientales cap le
samedi 11 juillet sur l'angleterre du
xviie siècle avec la musique baroque
d'henry purcell
[Musique]
m
le 18 juillet sera consacré aux musiques
du siècle d'or espagnol
trois concerts trois univers musicaux
différents voulue par le directeur
artistique de ces manifestations
jérôme correas directeur musical de
l'ensemble et paladin le public de saint
quentin les connaît bien cet ensemble
puisqu'on l'a accueilli à plusieurs
reprises très souvent sur la musique
baroque ski sa spécialité dont il
connaît bien le territoire il connaît
bien par royal aussi donc le contact
avec fit plus est avec le musée national
a été extrêmement simple et c'est pour
ça qu'on a été plutôt très réactif on
savait ce qu'on pouvait faire
tout le monde se connaissait toutes les
forces en présence se connaissaient à
chaque rendez vous une heure de voyage
musical en plein air tout en respectant
les gestes barrière port du masque
obligatoire tout comme la réservation